my original teacher was Jim Rohn when I
met him when I was 17. and I wanted to
know why all my fathers were broke
because they were good men you know I
loved all four of my fathers and I
remember him saying Tony we're all equal
as Souls
but we're not equal in the marketplace I
was like what does that mean and he said
well think about it he goes you need to
become more valuable
if you want to have economic freedom he
said you have to work on yourself more
than anything else and you have to work
on in a way where there's something you
can do for others better than anyone
else or at least more a better quality
and he gave me an example of like
working at McDonald's and he said you
know if you work at McDonald's you make
whatever it was in those days five
dollars an hour whatever it was and I go
yeah but that seems so unfair and he
goes yeah and teachers I give example of
teachers and there's these billionaires
you know that make a billion dollars in
a year hedge fund guy you know and he
said Tony the guy you just mentioned he
provided a 40 return last year and that
went to non-profits everything else he
said that means those organizations
double their money almost every two
years he is adding massive value
hundreds of billion dollars they made a
billion he goes this person is doing a
job that anyone can learn in 20 minutes
or half a day so it's a beginning job he
said you got you got to think of it as
one thing it's all about adding value
how can you do more for others than
anybody else in the world and that stuck
with me I mean I was like I decided I
wanted to do more friends than anybody
in the world in order to do that I had
certain skills and I went after those
skills and I still do it like it's a
never-ending thing if you think you're a
master you're full of it right so I
think that's probably some of the best
advice I've received at least on life
and business and Direction and it
affected my mission need motivation
watch the top ten with believe Nation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that Push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best Tony Robbins
and my take on his top 10 success enjoy
rule number two change your psychology
the difference between making it or not
is psychology and skill you need them
both and honestly skill is a smaller of
the two I'm going to give you a ton of
strategies this week I'm gonna do
psychology first and you're going to see
why as this day goes by because you're
going to discover when people stand up
and we figure out what's the choke hold
on their business 80 of the time it's
going to be their psychology
the choke hold on the growth of your
business is the psychology and skills of
the leader
period
that's it
and if we change those two things skills
two marketing skills Financial
intelligence recruiting training all
those things between those two don't get
me wrong we got to do the skills also
but I can give you every skill how many
of you've learned it before that was
invaluable from some Source a mentor a
coach an event a university I don't know
what and you were excited about it and
then you never actually followed through
who's done this before say I
listen knowledge is not power
execution Trump's knowledge every day of
the week
my goal is make you execute and I can't
make you but I can get you when you tap
into that part of yourself and that
shift is the most important shift of
these few days rule number three unlock
your own true nature all of us we could
take our work and think of work as being
like a gift I personally believe that
one of the greatest gifts outside my
love that I can give another human being
is my labor but there's three gifts of
Labor you might have within your nature
meaning you can Master anything but
under stress people tend to go back to
their true nature
and there are three gifts of Labor that
you can give
one of those gifts we might call the
gift of being an artist or a talent or
another word for it to be a truly
skilled producer
some people the reason you know this is
your gift is what you love to do is to
create a product or service and deliver
it to people and you're enamored by that
the woman over here who is doing the
work if you recall you know in hospice
she would be a perfect example of an
artist she's not in it she wants to make
money don't get me wrong but she would
never trade the money for the impact
so when someone is in it as an artist
and by the way most businesses are
started by artists
there's somebody who is an amazing
negotiator an amazing fashion designer
amazing code writer and they said I work
for this company and they don't do a
good job for customers and I can do a
better job I don't work for them and
they start their own company thinking
that the company is all driven just by
the sales or the negotiation or the code
or the fashion but a company is much
more complex than that especially as it
grows
so an artist is in it for the impact and
yes they want to make money don't get me
wrong but it's not the first thing and
they won't trade it when I talk to
artists about selling their business
they look at me like I'm trying to sell
their child
the second gift you might have
is the gift of being a manager leader a
manager leader is someone who lives to
manage people and processes they love to
figure out how to maximize a business by
changing the gears creating a new
process working with people and those
people love it now they are not artists
in that their talent or skill they're
not there delivering it directly to the
client they want to work on the people
that are directly or not they want to
work on the system that makes this
business work and so they think it
differently they're inspired by
different things they make different
decisions is one better or worse than
the other yes or no no they're just
different and by the way you might say I
have both those skills I bet you do but
they're not equal
because there are different types of
skills so you might have them both but
there's one that is your true nature
that when things are going well you're
going to go back to it when things are
really [ __ ] up you're going to go back
to it under stress and under excitement
we return to our Nature by the way a
great company can't be great without
great artists Talent who really deliver
extraordinary products or Services a
company cannot maintain greatness and
grow unless they have some great manager
leaders who can run with the process and
the people they're both critical
components the third choice of service
the true gift you can give is that of an
entrepreneur
and while most of you in this room call
yourself an entrepreneur and you would
be entrepreneurial
by this definition it's a little
different most people think of an
entrepreneur as anybody starts multiple
businesses no that's not true
some artists are multiple businesses
because they want to get all kinds of
things for all kinds of people some
managers want to do multiple businesses
so they feel like they have multiple
systems but entrepreneurs in it for one
thing the juice of risk
they want to make money
and by the way an entrepreneur will they
sell this business yes or no for the
right price they'll sell anything and
their mindset is sell it I'll start
another one sell it I'll buy another one
they are not attached they might enjoy
the product service that might be proud
of their product or service but they're
in it for the risk and they're the kind
of person that when they lose massively
they jump up dust themselves off and
want to do it again rule number four be
creative and caring lifestyle is not
about money
it's about two things
creativity and caring
it doesn't take money it just takes a
little creativity to think about those
you love and think light them up it will
light you up more than anything else I
promise you foreign
to do beautiful special things Little
Things
it makes people feel
important needed loved appreciated
what better way to invest
than invest in your relationships to
those you love
and you can't give joy to everybody else
that you love without giving joy to
yourself
and then there's another kind
the other kind is where you invest in
those you don't even know
not for stars on your chart
because you know it's right it can be
done with such a small amount of money
it's not money it's creativity and
caring
maybe it's animals that are abused maybe
it's old folks that people don't pay
attention to anymore
maybe it's providing one Searcher for
someone who has lost sight and can see
again
provide water for a family also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five set a large
purpose it's a purpose larger than
yourself that keeps you going if it's
only to meet your own needs you will
drop back into your comfort zone but
again for example you know one of the
great things that came out of covid is
I've spent most of my life as a vagabond
because I travel all over the Earth so
in most you years I traveled to you know
115 cities and as you know most my
seminars are multi-day seminars and I go
to 12 to 16 countries you know like
Australia three times and so all of a
sudden covet hits and I had to adapt I
found this way to adapt and now I'm
reaching 10 times I mean my largest
seminar is now 900 000 people versus
fifteen thousand I was trying I did one
football stadium in 2019 with 38 000
people 40 000 people it was incredible
now that's a tiny seminar you know
because I couldn't buy 900 000 people in
any Stadium right so all this good comes
from that adaptation right figuring out
what to do but I think the other part of
it is you know during that same time
when the great gifts was I could find a
way to be home and still touch people's
lives so deeply and do it in a way that
was impactful I could see it and feel it
and then they're home I could see their
children I mean it's been amazing and
now I do both I do hybrid I got a
thousand people in front of me and 197
countries all around me but one of the
other benefits was is we we'd want to
have a daughter and I told my wife I'm
not having a kid after 50. I don't want
to show up at high school reunion and be
70 years old but now I got an I got a
night I've got a 48 year old daughter
and a nine month old daughter give you
an idea
but my daughter like all the things I've
ever done for myself biohacking and
health and all that stuff like now I'll
be 80 at her High School reunion so I I
gotta use these things for a different
reason and so that doesn't let me get to
a certain level and stand there it's
like man you know I gotta be 92 to 102
range in order to do that I gotta know
every tool in the tool book to turn
around so gave me even more drive and
then what comes out of that now is I can
help anybody I mean you know this is my
new book by the way it's called life
force
February the 8th but you can pre-order
it now on Amazon or go to Tony
robbins.com but the point is it's like I
want to know every single tool like I
got totally obsessed even more than I
normally am because it's like okay I got
a higher purpose I got all my grandkids
all my children but now I got my
daughter rule number six learn to
overcome difficulties dealing with the
loss of someone you care about is
probably the most difficult thing of all
I would say maybe uh as a child seeing
the level of frustration between my
parents you know I had four different
fathers and watching them kind of um
you know accept whatever life gave them
as a it's why a lot of my drive came
about is seeing my father's be berated
by my mother who I love dearly
um and just watching them break down
like you know probably the single most
painful event in my life but also shaped
me in such a beautiful way was when I
was 11 years old we had no money for
food and it was Thanksgiving which in
America is a you know big holiday feast
and so we've been without food before we
have crackers and butter and you know we
survived but we weren't gonna have a
Thanksgiving feast and there's knock out
the door and I go to the door and
there's this giant guy there with
groceries in each hand he had a pot
beside him on the ground with an
uncooked turkey and I I just like I said
uh who are you here for he goes I'd like
to speak to your father and my mom and
dad were yelling at each other saying
things that you can never take back and
I'm trying to make sure my younger
brother and sister they're five and
seven years younger wouldn't hear any of
this and
that day changed my life because I
thought it was gonna be the most
exciting day
dad dad go to the front what is it I
said it's for you you answered no it's
for you and I remember we opened the
door and I was just so excited to see my
father be happy like we're gonna have a
feast this is going to be incredible and
he got angry and it's like we don't
accept charity he went to slam the door
in the man's face and the man's foot was
there so it bounced off his foot
they still open the groceries he's like
sir I'm just the delivery guy he said
it's it's not charity everybody has a
tough time someone bought this and
they're sending it to you as a gift and
my father said we don't take charity
goes to close the door again
this time the guy's shoulder was there
also so it bounced off again and then I
was standing right there and there's
this moment I'll never get where the
this man looked at my father and he
looked at me and he said sir don't let
your ego make your family
uh suffer
and the veins of my dad's face on the
side of his neck I'll never forget they
bulge like his face turned around I
thought I was gonna punch him in the
face and then there's this moment my
dad's shoulders dropped he took the
groceries slammed the door didn't say
thank you and stormed off and I always
remember thinking
like how come he's not happy you know
you talk about pain it's like I love my
father so much and he there's basically
three decisions that I think everybody
makes in their life that when they're
aware of it or not moment to moment I
figured this out afterwards because I
was so obsessed with what's wrong
because he eventually left our family
and that was the most painful thing I
ever have so it's like feeling like I
failed you know I blame myself like why
couldn't it get through to my father
when I was 11 years old but later on it
helped me understand the three decisions
are First You're Gonna decide what to
focus on every moment of your life
there's something grabbing your focus
and you don't experience life you
experience the part of life you focus on
right what's wrong is always available
so is what's right right
and there are different kinds of focus
and my dad's Focus that day was really
on what he hadn't done and I know that
because he kept muttering it and I
hadn't taken care of his family it was
no funny for Thanksgiving somebody had
to give us charity and then the second
decision you make about once you focus
on something is what does it mean
is this the end or the beginning if you
think it's the end of a relationship
you're going to behave different than
it's the beginning right
um my dad's meaning was that he was
worthless
and so then the third decision is what
do I do which whatever meaning you come
up with creates the emotions which
affects what you do and what he's got to
do is leave her family but for me it was
like this is amazing I mean you know we
are having thanksgivings you know this
isn't this is incredible we have food
what a concept and then the meaning
though is what changed my whole life
which was wow strangers care
that completely changed my life that
painful experience I couldn't deny that
somebody who wanted no credit
delivered this food to my family and so
what I decided to do is say someday I'm
going to do this for another family so
when I was 17 I had two families and it
was a euphoric experience I went in
jeans and a t-shirt I didn't go like the
delivery guy but I wanted to see the
face of the people and then next year
was four people and then it was eight
and literally my thing was doubling and
I had a little company and then I got to
a million people a year and I got to
four million people a year then when I
was doing money Master the game I'm
interviewing these billionaires Jay and
I'm watching Congress cut food stamps
it's now called the snap program by I
think it was six billion dollars so
every family that actually needs food
and my family was one of those back then
they all have to come up with a week's
worth of food out of every month so I
was like call my team and I said how
many people have I fed my lifetime I
didn't know there was 42 million meals I
was like this is pretty cool and I was
like What if I fed 50 million people
like my entire lifetime in one year and
I was like what if I did 100 man what if
I fed a billion people in 10 years so
that was seven years ago we're at 850
million meals right I'm gonna hit the
billion earlier than what I promised and
targeted and then I've got a sustainable
approach but I tell you that because
my worst day was my best day my the most
painful day of the day where I felt like
I'd do the least where I felt infinite
led me to have new understandings new
skills new capacities new drives new
Hunger I mean would I really be feeding
100 million people a year 100 million
meals a year if I was well fed as a
child probably not and I'd love to
believe I'm such a perfect person but no
I'm just I just know what suffering
feels like so I don't want anybody else
to suffer you know so I think sometimes
the suffering experiences of our life if
we don't let them crush us we let them
drive us they they actually become the
best day in your life and taking your
worst day and making your best day is a
beautiful Target for anybody rule number
seven live in a beautiful state for most
of my life like how people achieve
accomplish everything achieve make it
happen and if you ask me as fulfilled it
say of course I was and I was I loved it
but there's different levels of
fulfillment right if you've never
smelled a rose and someone's telling you
what a rose is like you think you know
to experience it yeah so I had this
experience in India I go about every two
years and there's a friend of mine there
who's built this amazing facility and he
had like a quarter million people
showing up for his event they expected
they would have you know I think they
had a hundred thousand people and a
quarter million people showed up and
then a million two by the next morning
and the guy that was there is a really
smart guy and so I had a conversation
with his son and he was thanking me for
all this work I've done he goes Tony of
all the things you've taught me he said
I think maybe the most important thing
is all the ways I can change my state I
can get unstuck I can I can give myself
the follows true because it is priceless
and he really thanked me and I said well
I really appreciate it and more
importantly you're using it right it
goes but I just have one little thing
I'd like to ask you
he goes you know you talk about if
you're in a peak State you get Peak
Performance or if you're an energy rich
State a high energy State you're going
to produce differently than a low energy
state or a lousy State and said yeah he
goes well what if you call those high
energy states beautiful States
I said that's great because it's not
just happiness a beautiful state could
be excitement it could be gratitude it
could be love it could be kindness it
could be warmth it could be I mean
there's a million beautiful States it's
any high energy state where no one has
to tell you what to do you'll do the
right thing so he goes okay I said so
yeah beautiful State's great and then he
goes what do we cook all those lousy
States those low energy states those
those types of States and what we call
those suffering and then when he said
that you're probably kind of like what
you experienced you're like nod at me a
little bit it's like suffering I don't
like suffering I don't suffer but I do
have times when I'm frustrated or
distressed or overwhelmed so I couldn't
deny it so I was like okay yeah those
would be suffering States I felt this
little trap going on in me yes why do
you say this yes he goes Tony because I
think it's the most important
distinction you've made but I like to
use some other words around it you guys
because I've set a spiritual vision for
myself so what's that he said my goal is
to live in a beautiful state every day
no matter what he goes to me that would
be the most gorgeous life because you
know people have anything and they're
miserable they're pissed off they're
frustrated and so forth because you deal
with them all the time I said that is
brilliant but I change it slightly for
me I'd say life is too short to suffer
to me that's where it starts Life's too
short and summer how could I possibly
suffer when I've been able to live this
magnificent life it's just the mind if
you don't direct this thing it directs
you it's like you use the mind or uses
you you use stress or stress uses you
yeah and so I said you know okay so how
am I going to do that this is one thing
to say it yeah if you want to develop
the habits yeah right and when I found
myself like getting on a plane and you
know I have my own plane now obviously
but the time I used to go to Australia
four times a year and I'd fly on Qantas
and when I moved to Florida it became 20
hours each way like a 40-hour trip for
one little visit yeah and I remember
getting on the plane being so stressed I
thought to myself Tony how can you be
stressed you're flying in a plane you
can fall asleep you can you know it's
not my size bed obviously but I'm in
first class and I'm very lucky
it's like come on what do you what do
you
realized what it was was that they had
no internet
so now I'm flying for 40 hours and
what's happening all my slacks all my
emails all my texts oh it's all growing
fortunately I got this resolved in my
head before I got like I'm lucky enough
to have my own plane and I remember when
I got worked out I got on a plane I flew
from here to LA
I got in plain La in the you know the
tapping comes on it goes uh this is
Captain stubble buying it's gonna be a
beautiful flight to Sydney and man he
said something I never heard before he
said today I have a special announcement
and it's this we have for the first time
in history of Qantas International
really people stood up on the plane and
cheered and I want to stand up to
everybody see me right so I stayed there
so we all open up our iPads our our
phones are everything we got right we're
all typing doing our stuff and social
media
and nine minutes later what do you think
happened it breaks down it crashes
turned on again
but you never
and the thing that struck me out and
it's changed my life is I looked around
me and people were angry they were
cursing with the house wrong with this
airline that you can't get this [ __ ]
right
I looked around I was like
this is amazing nine minutes ago this
was a miracle now it's already an
expectation oh God and I realized all
the unhappiness comes from all those
expectations you can't help to have the
Mind expect but you can direct it and
when you expect something it's not met
you get upset
and it's like if the only time I'm happy
is when everybody meets my expectations
I got 105 companies I got 3 800
employees on four continents what are
the chances someone screwing up right
now meaning doing something different
than I think they should 100 so it's
like I need to make it so that other
people don't have to behave a certain
way for me to be happy rule number eight
serve the secret to living is giving
because you're never going to be happy
by what you get
you get it you'd be excited for a while
for how long but
something you
whether other people
come as a man or as a woman as a soul
so business is a spiritual game how can
I do more for others than anybody else
how can I do it consistently I could do
it better how can I fall in love with my
clients and to over deliver levels they
can't even imagine
and develop this beautiful relationship
of such Joy it isn't a transaction there
are transactions involved but you're not
doing it for the transaction you're
doing it to make that difference in
their business or their life when you're
driven by a mission more than yourself
you get a level of energy that people
are just trying to think of themselves
will never have so my heartfelt wish for
you my dear friends is remember what
business is it's a spiritual game
it's about what can you give not what
can you get
you'll get plenty if you'll give much
more than you expect to receive if you
do that you'll have more than money
you have a life of incredible meaning
and your life will be blessed rule
number nine improve your values right
now you don't have to out of covid so
many people have been shut down in a
terrible place and you know I'm sure
you've seen that drug overdoses are the
largest they've ever been in history is
over 100 000 people last year suicides
one out of four kids under the age of 30
according to the CDC with their accurate
or not I don't know have considered
suicide sometime in the last two years
because we all need a compelling future
we need to look something to look
forward to so Stanford came to me and
the their genetics lab has been doing
research on depression and what they
found was that on by doing meta studies
is only 40 of the people who go in for
therapy who they get drugs and therapy
together usually only 40 make any
Improvement sixty percent don't improve
at all that's not a lot more than what
you can get on some placebos and so they
approached me and said a couple of
people went through one of your programs
one was clinically depressed they're not
anymore but we don't have any science on
this would you be one of us do a science
test and I said sure So they came out to
the statement Destiny seminar I do which
helps people to change their values and
belief structures I don't tell them what
they need to be but they figure out what
it needs to be and it changes the way
you perceive life the way you experience
life how you feel what you do it's a
rewiring of your model of the world
basically in six days and so they said
we're going to model this after the
greatest breakthrough they found in
science and no one able to follow up on
they about two years ago Johns Hopkins
did a study on depression
and they get people psilocybin right
which comes from magic mushrooms and
they did therapy for 30 days and at the
end of it 53 of the people were
depression free 30 days later never
happened like when we say 40 or helped
the average amount of help is 50 less
depressed right that's what the average
is some people completely turn around
some people don't know in this one 53 of
the people so it's four times the result
of any drug that ever been done but
unfortunately psilocybum is not legal so
they're still working on that and they
said we're going to copy that exact
study and we're going to have a group
that they compared to which is then go
to the seminar the comparison group is
going to do gratitude journaling and so
forth because positive psychology talks
about that and they said that's probably
what this seminar does is just positive
thinking well the cool thing was when
they came out the results were so
amazing at Stanford that they went and
had two new additional double-blind
people do the research because it just
seems so ridiculous at the end of oh the
first week 63 percent of people had no
had no uh depression symptoms at the end
of six weeks it can increase Through
Time a hundred percent of the people had
no no depression symptoms 19 of the
people had uh suicidal ideation zero had
suicidal ideation and blows away any
spending it just came out it's coming
out next week in the psychiatric Journal
which is General Medical Association
psychiatic Journal are the two top
journals in the field they can't even
believe it so they're going to do more
and there's the actual scientific
article says this is more powerful than
any drug therapy or any forms of normal
therapy combined and what are we doing
we're getting people to change basically
those three questions to some extent
because your values control what you
focus on if you're security driven and
you're here down in my basement right
now you're like where's the exit right
you came down a slide like how do I get
out of here right if you're Adventure
driven you don't care you don't even
know where it is so your focus is
controlled by your values and your
belief systems yeah right the meaning of
things that's controlled by your belief
systems so those three decision-making
things you know what I'm going to focus
on what does it mean what I'm going to
do shift and one good example of this
Jay is maybe your audience can relate to
this
so we just took three patterns so let's
say Focus most people have a focus
either on what they have or what's
missing we both we all do both
but what do you think most people focus
on more often what they have or what's
missing what's missing that's right now
even Achievers do that like I thought
like somebody's not successful it's one
of the reasons you see these Achievers
that no matter what they do it's never
enough because think about if you're
always focusing what's missing from your
life how can you sustain happiness it's
software that will not allow that you'll
feel happy for a little moment that
you'll notice is missing again
um what do you think's more often people
focus on what they can control or can't
control well they can't control yeah in
my seminars it's can control that's why
they go I want to learn how to control
my body or my finances or my business
whatever it is so it's the opposite but
the average person it's what they can't
control and with covid there's so much
you can't control around you that people
really sunk in that well how's someone
going to feel just everyone think about
it if you're constantly focused on
what's missing from your life and what
you can't control
and they'll add one more
do you took us more on the past
the present or the future we all do all
three but we tend to have one we focus
more on or do you think more people
focus that's right and Achievers focus
on the future and happy people in the
present and we'll number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
love more it's about growing and giving
I know that's overly simplistic but
that's what I want for her it's like you
know it's about laughing loving growing
giving you know and giving passionately
and generously and graciously it doesn't
I don't mean just money I mean of your
presence you know it's very easy to say
hello and not be there it's very easy to
say I love you and you know it's just a
habit you know about you know depending
on which studies you read about 47 to 52
of things we do are just habit the cool
thing about habit is it allows you do
other things like you know trying to
drive a stick shift car in the beginning
is way it's overwhelming now it's one
thing I can do 20 other things right but
the problem with it is
technology has made us become more and
more habitual and less and less
connected and so for my daughter I
wanted her to experience love that's
what life is to me and when you are
loving you have to grow to keep loving
and you when you're growing and you're
loving you're going to give and to me if
that's all she does if she learns that
life is not what you're here to get it's
what you're going to give that you're
being called to find what you're called
for and I don't know what should be
called for she you know may she might
sing she might draw art she might just
be a mom she's not just one of the most
important things in life she might I
don't know what she'll do and I have no
frame of reference about how she's going
to do it I have only one frame of
reference she's going to be a person
that's earned it and she's going to be a
person who's proud of herself because
the earned part to me is where the pride
comes it's like I have this amazing life
you can take away all the toys and
things that I have you couldn't change
who I've become as a man yeah and and
also because I never had those things
and I earned those things there's
there's the the stories and the examples
and you know what it's like right to
conquer all the challenges to get there
I want my daughter to have all those
experiences but to me life is love and
life is growing and giving it's really
that's what the whole game is about as
far as I'm concerned
to me a breakthrough is a moment in time
it's a moment when the impossible
becomes possible and you know just think
about it they act upon it you know it's
like you can have a concept that doesn't
create a breakthrough the breakthroughs
and you get to the point where you
actually are going to do something about
it and I ask people all the time I ask
your listeners or viewers as well it's
like I'm sure you've had a time where
you struggle with something right you're
gonna do something about this
relationship but you keep not changing
it right you know pulling back or you're
going to stop smoking or you're going to
go lose those 25 pounds or whatever it
is and you start to make progress and
then you pull back and you get
disappointed and get frustrated but then
there's some times where finally you hit
this threshold you hit this moment where
your brain says not another day not in
an hour I'm changing this relationship
I'm losing this weight I'm making this
happen and people create that
breakthrough and it can be happen if you
know it's the difference between what
triggers it versus what makes it
possible what triggers it is usually
pain or massive inspiration nothing in
between does it most people they hit a
threshold of pain and say it's like you
know I ask people how many of you ever
been in a relationship way too long and
everybody raises their hand they go why
why just stay you weren't happy they
weren't happy it's just because of the
unknown the uncertainties the the idea
of change it could be worse you know to
be alone but then there's that moment
when you finally hit the threshold you
go it's been painful in the past it's
painful now it's gonna be painful you're
talking about change it now so the
trigger that finally made that happen
I'd ask your audience if they think of
something where they finally broke
through what was the trigger usually
that moment that day you hit a threshold
of I can't take anymore I'm changing or
something inspired you you saw some as
possible and they can do it I can do it
as well but that's what makes it
possible what makes it last is a change
in your emotions or changing your belief
system or a new strategy right you and I
both know because you're both
strategists the right strategy how you
can consume a book and remember more of
it in 30 or 45 minutes than you did when
you used to spend 10 days on the damn
book right you know it's the right
strategy but you're not going to find
the strategy until it's a must for you
amount of [ __ ] you know what I mean or
if that change in belief looks like okay
I've put up with this crap long enough
I'm better than this there's something
more in me that you finally finding
yourself or you finally get pissed off
enough or you get excited enough to make
that real change and so what I've
studied is
I like to take complex things that make
them simple because I found that you
know the more you know when I was really
young I tried to make things more
complex I think to try to convince
myself how smart I was or other people I
don't know what but it's stupid because
complexity is the enemy of execution and
the only way your life changes or your
business changes is execution so it's
like how do you make it simple and I
started looking at all these you know
I've been doing this this is my 45th
year doing this I started when I was two
of course and and I started seeing these
patterns all over the world working with
the greatest people on Earth athletes
business people the most challenged
people in prisons like what are the
common denominators and all these
cultures and I began to see there's
three things you need for a breakthrough
but most of us do them in reverse order
so we don't get the Breakthrough the
number one thing most people do when
they want to have a breakthrough they
don't they want to change their body
they want to change their Finance they
look for a strategy which makes common
sense that's what I used to do
but the problem is
strategy could be the problem and maybe
you need a better strategy but that's
not usually the real problem right like
for example three quarters of America is
overweight or obese if we're the fattest
humans in the history of the world we
all know covid other than age the number
one risk factor is obesity that's number
one and yet very few people do anything
about it and why is that is it because
you know the strategy for being fit and
strong is so complex or only the one
percent know it or it costs a fortune to
do it now you have to be fighting not to
see all the strategies that make your
body physically better around you
everywhere so it's you could have the
wrong strategy like I remember years ago
on the cover of Time Magazine they have
the Atkins diet and they said you know I
think it was 15 of Americans were doing
it well if you gotta pee on a stick so
you don't get too acidic and your breath
is that bad it's pretty obvious that's
not sustainable so sometimes it's a
strategy problem but we work for the how
first and you've never figured it out
your emotions get in the way it's the
wrong sequence it's like the dog bit
Johnny Johnny bit the dog same words
different experience of your Johnny so
strategy naturally is where people go
but rarely do they change with that what
the real problem usually is the story
they've developed and a story is just
code for all the things you've told
yourself over and over again until you
believe them right there's an old a
language pattern that says tell why big
enough loud enough long enough sooner or
later people believe it that was Hitler
said that and so most of us are Hitler
in our own mind so it's not that they
can't you know what do people say how
come a capitalist wait I can't lose
weight because you know I've tried
everything no if you tried everything
you'd be fit right they didn't try
everything I've tried millions of things
really name them well I've tried
hundreds name them and then they'll tell
you three stupid things that don't work
that they did over and over again right
so it's the story I I don't have a
relationship because all the good ones
are gone or they're gay and I'm not or
I'm gay and they're not or whatever the
story is the story is what will keep you
like I'm sure you know Jim you have so
many great strategies you share with
people how do you have times when you
give someone an answer right there in
front of them and they just can't even
see it right they don't believe it
because the story is literally blinding
them in Psychology we call it a scotoma
a blind spot
but then there's one level deeper than
even the story
and that's your state the mental
emotional physical state you're in
because when you're in a low mental
emotional physical state
you can have all the brain capacity in
the world but you're not going to use it
and so when you're in a lousy State you
come up with a lousy story and then no
strategy works it doesn't matter what it
is if I don't know if you've ever
noticed have you ever gotten really
angry at somebody and then suddenly you
remember all the ways they've ever
screwed you over you've been upset with
them right but on the other hand you
fall in love and what's wrong with life
nothing I have no money it doesn't
matter we're in love it's all wonderful
right so this is the sequence in which
we do things accelerates or decelerates
or stops progress when it comes to a
breakthrough and what I found is change
the state first you you're like we you
and I can talk and give people a million
strategies
but if I'm sitting here at home and this
State and I'm just listening like this
and nodding like this yeah that makes
nothing's gonna happen
so the reason that I've done events over
my lifetime and the reason why I do
immersion events you know 10 12 13 hours
a day you learn a little bit at a time
like language you don't remember the
language a few years later but I drop
you in Rome and say you got no teacher
and you got 60 days I'll be picking you
up I'll pick you up 60 days from now
you're going to be speaking Italian
right especially if I put you maybe with
some passionate people who are really
going for it in their life you're gonna
have a whole different state about you
you're going to develop a new story and
you're going to figure out the strategy
so I think the the challenge for most
people especially with covet is we've
all had our state dropped people have
been isolated they've been pushed at
home they've had expectations that have
fallen away like I remember a year ago a
lot of people are like all right we got
vaccines now it's a new year it's going
to be a brand new thing you know 2021
now this year you talk a lot of people I
don't even have any goals or anything
because they've gone to learned
helplessness because they've been
disappointed so many times they start
thinking the problem's forever no
problems forever no war is forever no
pandemic is forever your mind is weak
now and it's gotten a weak habits and
you're in a lowered state so you start
to believe that and so it's like you got
to change people's State first then you
got to give them the story that can help
them they need to give them the
strategies that work in there even if
you don't give them a strategy they'll
figure out their own strategy you're a
perfect example of that right you've
figured it out because you got yourself
to the point where it's like I've got to
turn this around and then you have
something that you can give and that
expands your life as you've experienced
it disappointment either destroys you or
drives you and you have to decide which
one it's going to be if you don't
consciously decide there's always going
to be more BS for you to deal with and I
think but that's why I think you know
when I do my events the reason I do the
12 hours a day it's not because I like
talking it's just that I can tell you
something all day long or I can get you
to build the muscle yes and the building
muscle is by experiencing and I always
tell people a belief I believe it's a
poor substitute for an experience like I
could have a belief about you and I
experience you so I get to know who you
are right the same thing's true is like
you have a belief about China you have a
belief about working out so I try to
give people experiences that are so
profound and then you know the the
studies they did they found people 12
months later 11 months later they're
still in the middle of covet they did my
digital seminar and you know they
measured my body like the amount of
times I jump I jump a thousand times in
a day and I weigh 282 pounds and I come
down four times the body weight so it's
a thousand pounds times a thousand
pounds of pressure my lactic acid if
you've ever been with a friend and
you're running and you can't talk the
point you can't talk is the level four
of lactic acid I'm in an 18 and still
speaking so they decided to do that on
my audience
and they found an interesting pattern
it's the same group that works with some
of the you know Super Bowl champions and
some of the Stanley Cup champions and so
forth there's a ratio in the body of
testosterone versus cortisol the stress
hormone and when the ratio is balanced
they call it the championship bloodline
by our bloodstream it literally gets you
to follow through so when they did my
audience in my live seminar they found
that people literally mirror me all the
way through the experience God's
phenomenal chemically that is phenomenal
but then we did it on we did it you know
because all of a sudden overnight they
said to me you know we're going to San
Francisco and the governor of California
says you can only have 10 people
and we got 15 000 so I was like We'll go
to Vegas they'll never shut down Vegas
they shut down Vegas I was like okay
we'll do 1500 movie theaters with 10
people in him they shut down the movie
theaters like okay we'll go to a church
in Houston I got a buddy I'll rent his
church 15
000 people they're not gonna keep Costco
open and shut down the church they kept
Costco open and shut down the church so
I finally said okay I'm not gonna do
some crappy little webinar so I get this
Vision I'm gonna build this facility
with 20 foot high LED screens 50 feet
wide all around me I'm gonna call Eric
Young at Zoom I'm gonna get them from a
thousand up to 25 000 people so I could
interact with people live in real time
on a build an app so they can shake it
and the more people do it the louder it
gets so it's real so I built this whole
thing so now we're doing bigger events
than ever in our entire history but they
did the same measurements on them in
different parts of the world and saw the
exact same mirroring process and the
average person even digitally even the
smartphone ever yeah um 71 of the people
they had 71 drop in negative emotions 53
Improvement
lots of emotions and 11 months later in
the middle of covid it helped because
it's a biochemical change so when people
say oh I'm trying that's I write books
because it's it's an easy entry point to
people there's so much you can learn
from the book but there's nothing like
the experience that's why I do the
events and like those last two years
because of covet I did two like six day
free events we had 800 000 people at 10
for six days just four weeks ago because
I just wanted people to have answers
where they are and then people start to
see they get momentum but it's hard to
do just reading something or watching a
couple of you know you know 20 minute or
15 minute or five minute little pieces
on YouTube those are great they might
inspire you but a transformation
requires immersion it's like yes if you
ask the average person
did you study a foreign language in
school most people oh yeah High School
College speak it they don't but if you
turn around and you said okay what if
you want to learn Italian and I just
took you to Rome and dumped you off for
six weeks yeah with no teacher You're
Gonna Come Back six weeks later speaking
you know Italian so it's immersion and
if you want to master something I think
that's the thing most people don't do
they read a little bit they listen a bit
they dip in and out they don't go day
and night night and day in total
immersion and something that transforms
them and also something that makes them
push through their fears yes because in
the end it's the only thing that stops
everybody's got a story I didn't know
this person I don't have the resources
they have all the things they don't have
but if you're resourceful you can get
the money you can get the time you can
get the energy you can get anything you
want and you've got to get over your
fear to be resourceful so we do
experiences that are so physiologically
profound that those fears do not stop
you anymore yeah and that's what that's
how we get people to get you know 10
years later they're still transformed
from an experience that was one weekend
your happiness will never last as long
as it's got expectation behind it don't
get me wrong I at businesses I run them
we manage them but I know that people
are going to screw up or my idea script
is different than I think they should be
and sometimes their script will turn
into something even better right I got
to give it room so what I did was I
began to realize
I made the decision it's the most
important decision I believe of your
life that I'm not going to suffer
anymore Life's too short to suffer and
I'm going to live in a beautiful state
every day and the way I do it is I catch
myself when I start to get that sense of
stress I let it go and I see the eye to
go by so your thoughts thoughts about
this person messing up your business or
not following through if I was in a room
with 10 000 people I guarantee you 60 70
of the business owners have the same
thoughts at times right I ask people all
the time tell me your most stressful
thought oh I'm worried about my children
this may happen how many people have had
that for everybody uh you might not make
it financially well how many fact about
everybody my point is
it's not your thought it's the mind not
your mind when you think it's your mind
you identify with it and it's it can't
separate from yourself man but when you
realize these thoughts have been around
for millions of years
and I'm just thinking the same thought
that so many people thought before like
how many people have ever thought I'm
gonna kill the son of a [ __ ] now you
didn't do it because you didn't believe
you're really gonna kill them but you
felt it you said it you were there right
so we all have thoughts
it's only the stressful thoughts we
believe that messes up so what I try to
show people is if you can start to
realize these thoughts have been around
for millions of years have I told you a
million years you know a thousand
hundred years ago that we're gonna go to
the moon and back you called me a
lunatic or crazy if I said 100 years ago
you're gonna have a little box like this
it'll fit in your pocket and you can
click on it and you can see what the
weather is any place you could click on
it and see a live person on the other
side of the earth and talk to them by
looking this box and the way it works is
invisible waves or traveling around the
earth and it pulls invisible waves in
the Box you go like read between the
lines there's no way you dumb idiots so
what I want you to realize is thoughts
are invisible ways
you need to turn on a TV it takes
invisible waves and depending on the
channel you're going to see a love story
or an adventure or a drama or a comedy
or or a horror
the way you use your body determines
which of those thought waves come
through you one moment you're pissed off
the next moment somebody makes you laugh
you change your body you change the
channel you change what comes through
you so what I've tried to do in this
area beautiful state is simple yeah
first identify where you're suffering
what's your favorite flavor are you a
worrier are you a pissed off person
angry what is it you do yeah second of
all decide you're going to kill that
monster while it's little you're not
going to wait till it's Godzilla taking
a city you're going to break the pattern
you start to feel the stress you see it
as thoughts going by and then you focus
on someone you appreciate enjoy or love
appreciation love and joy destroy
suffering you can't be grateful and
angry simultaneously it's possible you
can't be worried and fearful and and
grateful simultaneously so I tell people
gratitude is one of the emotions to
cultivate that'll destroy the suffering
and that's what we teach people to do
you mentioned you reach out to someone
you'll text someone you'll send a voice
note or a video message or maybe you're
calling them or just saying hi to them
and telling them you're acknowledging
something that they're doing well that
you appreciate
I don't think that many people do this
why is this so important for you
personally and why do you think this
would help so many people get out of
themselves and overcome anxiety and
stress if they did this even a couple of
times a week I know you do this every
day but just a couple texts a week why
is this so valuable for people uh well
number one I love people so I love to
sincere if you just call someone to make
a compliment and it's not sincere
anybody can feel that I don't do that
you know it's like I I pride myself in
finding the goodness in people or the
skill sets in people and I also know
that what is acknowledged tends to grow
so from standpoint of that I want them
to feel that feeling of being
appreciated I want them to know I see
what's happening behind the camera so to
speak you know it's like that's what
matters it's not how everybody else sees
you it's how you really are and then it
also deepens every relationship you have
when you sincerely acknowledge somebody
and you notice something other people
don't notice and so it deepens the
connection and to me quality of life is
the quality of two things your emotions
and your relationships and you know if
my emotions are terrible my
relationships are going to be terrible
but if I have great emotions and I can
extend that help other people then it
just makes me feel more alive so I I do
it for me and them it's it's a virtuous
cycle I just hate to see people limited
I hate to see people suffering suffering
I've suffered enough myself I don't want
anybody else to suffer and I I'm lit up
by being able to see people readily take
control of their life and we can't
control everything obviously they're
things beyond our control but there's so
much within our control that people give
up because they're afraid or they don't
want to fail or they're just just offer
frustrating overwhelmed or stressed and
so what I've managed to do is to take
fundamental principles that can change
the way you think and the way you feel
and the way you behave your finances
your body your emotions your
relationships have been obsessed for
principles that can make that happen but
I'm pretty good at creating an
environment where I create a community
very quickly where 10 20 30 40 50 000
people in a room for three or four days
with me you know people who wouldn't sit
for a three-hour movie because you know
someone spent 300 million dollars on it
and you've been there on fifteen twenty
thousand people there for 50 hours in a
week and nobody leaves they can vote
with their feet and they get their money
back anytime they want they don't it's a
stadium full of people who become alive
in their different religions different
backgrounds different belief systems
different sexual preferences different
political views and yet we come together
for a higher good and to me that's the
most extraordinary experience but
there's an energy to it also because
ideas when people say knowledge is power
it's a lie knowledge is not power it's
potential power you know execution
trumps knowledge every day of the week
and my job is to get people to execute
and when you get people execute they get
momentum when they get momentum it's
self-fulfilling right okay I know who I
am now I know what I'm capable of and
you tend to go to higher and higher
levels of contribution of impact and
success if you're obsessed you know what
you want you take a Massive Action maybe
you modeled somebody to figure out the
right action so you get there quicker
and you're executing you still need a
little Grace
some people call it luck you could call
it God but I really believe that there's
the part we do and then there's the part
that comes to us but I do know gray
shows up a lot more when you do the
first two steps on your own and Grace
shows up a lot more when you acknowledge
Grace in your life when you acknowledge
that I was born in a world where I
didn't have to build this internet that
I can pull out of my pocket to answer
anything on Earth I'm driving on streets
I didn't pave I'm reading books I didn't
have to write that's the gift of our
lives and I think when we experience
that Grace we don't just experience more
achievement but we start to experience
more fulfillment and Grace not only
affects your ability to get there but it
affects what you do and how you you live
once you are there it really determines
the quality of your life because unless
you live in a state of gratitude you
know I I did an interview with Sir John
Templeton who as you know is one of the
first billionaire investors and just a
brilliant man he came from nothing and
he donated I think it was 750 they still
do it the Templeton fund I think it's
750 million dollars a year it's bigger
than a Nobel fund that he donates and
one day I asked them I said what is the
secret to wealth
and he looked at me pause this big smile
and his eyes got really bright like they
always did and he said Tony it's what
you teach I said well I teach a lot of
things you know which thing he said
gratitude he said because you and I Tony
know billionaires that are miserable and
it's because they're not grateful for
what they have and we both know people
have no money seemingly but they're so
grateful for their health for their
husband for their wife for their
children they're so grateful that God
they're so grateful for their life that
they're rich you know so I think I think
it starts with that gratitude it starts
with that connection to Grace as
simplistic as that sounds and so it's
not enough just to have your financial
plan you have all the money and be
miserable let's have the money and be
really rich emotionally psychologically
and spiritually you're really talking
about the most important Concept in
lasting change identity
we all Define ourselves in certain ways
and most of us defined ourselves years
ago and we haven't done an update and
now you're in an environment where
you're constantly told how bad it is how
terrible it is so that stimulates the
old part of the human brain the
fight-or-flight mechanism the part of
your brain is always looking through
what's wrong so you can hide from it you
know or you can fight it or you can
freeze and hope it doesn't notice or you
can run from it and so that part of our
brain is never going to make you happy
it's an important part there's no
saber-toothed tiger for us to run from
anymore or fight right not for most
people but now we get that about what do
people saying about me online or you
know or do I have enough money in a
country that even if you have very
little money in America even if you're
in quote unquote a poor environment you
know I I support I provide 100 million
meals a year I've done I'm almost a
billion meals now I'm at 825 million
meals to give you an idea in the last
seven years so I'm into helping everyone
one I possibly can but you got to help
them here and here too you know so I use
the food as the excuse to get into here
and here and start showing people what's
possible and I think we're in a place
right now where a lot of people are in
this learned helplessness and they don't
realize you know if you if if as an
identity if identity is how you've
identified yourself
and you see yourself as a procrastinator
why because you procrastinated so many
points and disappointed you don't want
to be disappointed so now you're a
procrastinator you're no longer
disappointed you feel certain you'll
never have your goals but you feel
certain that's what most people do in
their life but if you set let's say a
thermostat in this room at 78 degrees
and the temperature drops far enough
something's going to happen because the
computer's gonna go hey hey you're a 78
degree or what are you doing here in 68
and the heaters kick on and suddenly you
get this drive I'm sure your listeners
your viewers have had this experience
many times your life where Finance not
another day now I'm changing this
relationship I'm losing this waiter I'm
gonna finally do something and then you
push push push now some people push push
push and they go beyond their comfort
zone beyond what they expect not their
goals
it's what they're used to it's their
comfort zone and let's say that 68
degrees is where they're used to
financially it's not what they want or
their relationship or spiritually or
physically and they grow to 88 98 99
degrees suddenly the brain goes hey
what are you doing here
you're you know you're you're not a 99
degreeer
and then all of a sudden the heaters
stop and you lose your drive and if
that's not about the air conditioners
kick on and you start to sabotage and
you go what happened in my life so
identity is the number one thing I work
to change with people to expand it not
to get rid of it but expand your own
sense of who you really are and what
you're capable of and people think
they're going to get identity by people
say to me I have no self-esteem I hate
that word
so overused and abused I normally
self-esteem because when I was growing
up my parents said these terrible things
and those terrible things and I said
isn't it convenient you only remember
those things yes you know they said a
million things but suddenly he was
holding on those but let's get real
someone can tell you your whole life
you're a piece of crap but you can say
screw you read between the lines and
make your life work someone tell your
whole life you're beautiful you're
intelligent you're the smartest person
in the world and you don't believe it
because self-esteem doesn't come from
what people say about you self-esteem is
earned within you yourself
it's esteem for yourself which only
comes by doing things that are
incredibly difficult and then your brain
goes this is who I am the reason I've
done firewalks for years I used to do
skydiving but you know it's hard to get
30 000 people in the middle of the Year
above New York in the middle of the
night but the reason I did these
metaphors was because when someone does
something they once thought was
difficult or impossible and you get the
other side of the brain goes if I get
myself to do this what else could I get
myself to do it changes their identity
when your identity expands your whole
world expense if you're feeling sad or
frustrated coveted and you don't know
what's happened in the future and you're
uncertain you go like oh what do I want
I don't know because your mental
emotional state is the single most
important ingredient to not only success
but fulfillment and most of us do not
know how to manage it when I say manager
I'm really talking about your mind and
your emotions right those are the two
things that if you can Master those
because most people are trying to master
the outside world and you can't control
the outside world you can influence it
but the one thing you can control is how
you use your mind what you do with your
money and if you think about the quality
of your life you know again look at
people who supposedly have everything
and they're miserable I get those phone
calls from the people that are so quote
famous the great actors the great
musicians they won the Academy Award
They just won the gold medal and they're
literally depressed and the reason is
because they thought getting something
would eventually make them feel a
certain way and it does for this long
and then you're off to the next thing
and then well when you work so hard for
something forever like that it's not
there so what I really like people to
understand is that the quality of your
life
is the quality of your emotions
you have a billion dollars and every day
your habitual emotions are feeling
frustrated and stressed and overwhelmed
your life is called frustrated stressed
and overwhelmed if you have three
beautiful children and a great husband
or a wife or boyfriend or girlfriend and
every day you worry your life is not
love your life is worry it doesn't
matter how you have this beautiful
family so think of it emotions control
the quality of our life and we have
habitual emotions that's why you'll see
people who you know they're always angry
about something I'm sure you know
somebody like that or they're always
worried about something if they're not
worried about somebody if they know they
worry about something they don't even
know right or you know some people that
are you know think they're funny and
they're not but they have a good time
you know who do you want to hang out
with so learning how to direct your
emotions and emotions create everything
everything you want in your quote
unquote success will be driven by having
certain drives of emotion and you know
think about it emotions create Wars
emotions create peace eventually
emotions are what you get you in a
relationship emotions we all got here
you know somebody had sex and that was
driven by emotion so we are incredibly
emotionally unfit today you know we're
fearful about everything it's nobody's
fault it's just culturally we've been
conditioned to get everything instantly
by having it in our fingertips and our
phone or our iPad or our computer
whatever the case may be and so now when
people don't get what they want
immediately I'm sure you've seen
somebody standing on the street corner
and they're banging on their phone like
give it a minute it's going to a
satellite and back you know
people today have zero patience and then
that messes up the next part that's
really your life quality of life's
quality of your emotions
but your emotions are magnified by the
quality of your relationships
if you have terrible relationships it's
going to be hard to stay in a great
emotional state and so what I try to
teach people is what do you do to take
control of your mind and emotions and
fundamentally the most basic thing you
got to do especially at a time like
covet is you gotta every day have a
couple of simple practices one of those
is every day you got to feed your mind
and when I say Fiji Miami consciously
seek out something that's going to give
you new insight new inspiration new way
of looking things because otherwise
today the news follows you right it's in
your pocket and the news people are good
people but they're doing their job
what's their job make as much profit as
possible how do you get the most profit
get the most people to watch how you get
the most people to watch Fear if it you
know if it if it leads it leads is the
phrase they use in journalism right and
we've seen so much fear built up now
that most people have lost their faith
and you can't lose it fortunately it's
just a muscle that needs to be regained
but you have to fill your mind you have
to pursue it great ideas are not going
to interrupt you they have to be pursued
and the good news is today if you get
away from just the traditional news you
can do a good podcasts like boss babes
you can go to different locations you
can get another perspective and you can
feed your mind but if you don't feed
your mind my original teacher was a guy
named Jim Rohn and he used to say Tony I
got a question for it he said what if
your worst enemy put sugar in your
coffee what's going to happen to you
when you drink that coffee so you're
gonna have sweet coffee you he said you
know what if your family member your
friend Your Love by accident drops one
drop of strychnine what's gonna happen
when you drink their coffee is that
you're going to be dead he goes That's
Right life is sugar and strychnine so
watch your coffee like every day you
gotta stand guard at the door of your
mind especially at times like this when
there's so much fear so you feed your
mind and then the second thing you've
got to do is the mind and the body work
together meaning fear is physical but so
is courage have you ever been so scared
that you know like you have a hard time
swallowing or you feel like in your gut
you know that kind of fear that's
physical yeah but courage is not that
you're not afraid courage is you're
scared you know wetless but you're going
to do it anyway right that it's a muscle
and courage comes from doing something
physical so every day you got to feed
your mind and you got to do something
physical to push yourself beyond what
you're normally comfortable with meaning
go for a jog or a run or walk really
fast or go lift some weights a little
more than you used to because every time
you push yourself to go beyond what's
comfortable you get more comfortable
with a bigger Challenge and pretty soon
what was hard is easy and it isn't just
the weight or the run is what happens to
your mind and emotions because they work
together and then what you got to do is
really you got to find a great role
model and decide what do I want to go
after and let me have them show me away
show me the way at least the pattern
rather than me learning by trial and
error and I got to take action and then
ideally I got to help somebody's worse
off than I am because that'll give me
fuel it'll remind me that my life is
there you know you know I feed you know
100 million people every single year now
but because somebody fed my family when
I was young and it wasn't the food it
was that Thanksgiving somebody showed up
with a surprise and it showed that they
cared so I think if you were to take
control of your emotions then you can
take control of your entire life but
without that it's just a pipe dream it's
just more New Year's resolutions and
within six or eight weeks you're back to
where you were before it really comes
down to anyone can learn anything if
it's important enough to you what makes
it important to me is not just my own
life it's like if I have a problem my
shoulder my neck whatever and I can
solve it I know that there are millions
of other people can be helped by it so
it's like my drive is not just for me
that wouldn't be enough because it's
easy to meet your own needs it's not
that difficult but if you can find
something that you care about more than
yourself your daughter your son your
family your business your mission your
community whatever it is that's really
the secret to energy and vitality and
strength and really learning and I think
the other thing is
um complexity is the enemy of execution
uh one of the things I want to do with
people during this challenge is take
things that seem so complex and make
them so simple so you do it if you have
a business and you got this huge complex
plan you hired a giant consulting firm
they put it all together it never gets
implemented you know it you've been come
to your companies why because they make
it so complex and it's somebody else's
plan what I really want to do for people
at this challenge is get it really
simple things you can do right now to
change your life you can go to
experience it that day and then you get
momentum day one day two day three day
four and all of a sudden now what used
to be hard to do is easy to do and I
think for anyone you gotta understand
anyone can learn anything if you can
just break it down to its simple core
and that's what I try to do most
momentum is everything right the hardest
part in life is creating momentum so
when that all happened you know I had
built something of momentum over you
know 40 years literally at that point
around the world and you know what do
you do all of a sudden when you know
suddenly they say you can't do an event
with more than 10 people and you've got
15 000 people scheduled to take over the
stadium each and you know you know what
I did I went we're going to Vegas
they're never going to shut down Vegas
right but then they shut down Vegas I
was like I know I'm going to rent a
church a mega church from a buddy of
mine in Houston 15 000 people they're
not going to keep Costco open to shut
down the church they kept Costco open
shut down the church so I got to the
point where it's like what do you do and
when you think there's nothing you can
do that's when you can do something when
you think I don't know what to do that's
when you know what to do if you just
push yourself and so I was like I pulled
my team together I saw a guy do like a
webinar with two 52-inch screens and I
said I'll kill myself first I said I got
to create an experience for people they
need it desperately wherever they are in
the world so it's literally I pulled out
of tape recorders like okay here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna do 20 foot
high LED screens 50 feet wide highest
resolution in the world 0.67 150 you
know 50 degree 180 degrees around me
around the back I'm gonna call my buddy
Eric yon and I'm gonna see if Zoom we
can expand him from the little thousand
to twenty thousand or thirty thousand
I'm gonna hire a firm to create an app
so they can shake it so it sends a
signal and you can hear reality of
people clapping because the more shake
it the louder it gets and I just started
creating the whole thing in an hour
there someone's done my my CFO says uh
Tony um you know after you saw all the
numbers it was over 20 million bucks for
the time we're done just like Tony um
should we rent some of this first
and I said to him I said listen of all
first of all you can't I said go do your
best not what I'm looking for I said
second of all this is going to be this
way for a while yeah and we're going to
use this to help more people and that we
don't you know when things go back to
normal we get to go do that too and I
just did a date with Destiny where I had
you know uh 10 000 people from 97
countries and then I had 500 people in
front of me because I built the studio
so that there's 40 foot high ceiling so
I could literally lift the 20-foot
screen and so now I have a hybrid event
people don't want to come personally on
there people that want to be in the
middle of the night in some other
country are able to participate but all
that comes from just taking action and
momentum yeah if you build momentum you
can accomplish anything you've seen it
in sports you see a team that's
dominating and then somebody steals the
ball and the momentum changes yeah your
job right now is great momentum and
that's why I'm building this challenge
is basically to say to you let's do a
breakthrough for you right now so you
know it's real let's get you to get a
real result let's get you to shift
yourself physically and mentally and
emotionally so you can build that
momentum because it takes so much energy
to rock it out of the atmosphere things
very little take it out of the solar
system so that momentum I think is
critical most of us in life we work so
hard for things we think life's going to
be a certain way but as you're going to
discover life is never a straight line
you know we're taught that we think line
is just I'm gonna go from here to there
but if you look in nature you never see
a straight line in real nature if it's a
straight line a human built it and so
it's a process of evolving of growing
dropping back growing dropping back and
and challenges are what really grow us
you know your life is a great story you
know every person's life is a story and
the question is some people's story is a
warning some people's story is an
example right now you're an example
that's growing and expanding and you
have a chance to have this be the most
incredible life but it won't be a life
without Challenge and the challenges
we're facing right now give you an
opportunity to grow like very few
Generations you know I'm sure you've
heard of the great generation the World
War II generation if you watch a great
movie if you read a great book you know
the size and the power of the hero how
much you become problem as a hero is
defined by how tough an obstacle you
face how difficult is the villain the
opponent and so sometimes when I've been
through the toughest times of my life
one of the questions I've had to ask
myself or note to myself is ah I finally
have a really worthy opponent this is
scaring the hell out of me or this is
challenging me this is making me crazy
but I also know in my gut and my soul
that if I can push this just like you've
done in these years you've pushed
through tough times I'm sure of many of
them but as you push through those you
become more as you become more something
magical happens you don't just grow you
expand in your spirit and your soul and
your capacity and your skill and all of
a sudden fear becomes less and less a
part of you it's one of the things I've
got a dozen really important things to
me feeding people's most important to me
providing fresh water I do that in India
for a quarter million people a day
personally I'm gonna get that to a
million people in the next few years
it's about infrastructure uh freeing you
know boys and girls women or about 80 of
them I mean there's a new child abducted
every 30 seconds there's 6 million
people in slavery around the world
children and slavery sexual slavery
we've saved about 3 800 just the last
couple of years I've gone on the
operations myself undercover but what I
work with Underground Railroad because
they're former SEAL Team Six CIA FBI and
we teach the local government what to do
to capture these people so it's not just
Saul save some kids right now but
showing them what to do for the future
but I'm also you know I'm involved with
so many different things and my answer
is if I think it's it's core to humanity
that I'm interested food is here is you
know I planted 10 million trees in the
last year and a half you know I'm more
fortunate to have my own private jet but
I'm conscious of that so I was like how
many trees does my whole lifestyle takes
about 3 000 trees I said but I don't
plant you know 10 million I said Square
I'm probably 100 million so I planted 10
million already I'm on course to the 100
million just like feeding a billion
people so it's it's the things that
matter that's what God's good I do
things spontaneously I was in San
Francisco and I read in the newspaper
that while I'm there I've never seen
Mark benioff and I see that the the
toughest part of San Francisco is called
the tenderloin district and there's
these nuns there that feed the poorest
of the poor and they're being evicted
and you know it's the richest one of the
richest cities in the world more
billionaires there attack billionaires
anyway no one's doing anything so I just
I went over and knocked on the door
introduced myself found out who the
person was it was you know dick damn
called him up and said look I'm up I'm
an owner too you have the right to evict
anybody but do you really want to be the
haters man hated the man in San
Francisco I said why don't you let him
stay nine months I'll get them out
within nine months I'll pay you the
additional rent and I did and then you
you know the nuns like they're looking
for a place to lease and all of a sudden
I get a call from the Realtree because
they're looking for a place to buy and I
called the nuns and said you got some
money I don't know about God will
provide me so I bought them I bought him
a place there
Park many often bought them a home to
live in so you know I do things
spontaneously I love those things as
well but I mean like the secret to
living is giving I know it sounds corny
but I have a tough time in my life I
remember I was driving on the street in
this 1968 Volkswagen I was working so
hard and I was so frustrated things
weren't going the way I thought they
should and I was like what's wrong and
then I pulled it aside and I stole them
today this written drawer at the secret
to living is giving I started crying
because I lost the giving mode I was
just I got into the business mode and to
me like I said business is spiritual
game if you're focused on giving if
you're doing more for your client or
customer than anybody else you will
dominate doesn't matter what industry
you're in and that's what I've been able
to do with you know my 50 plus companies
where focus goes energy flows most
people are focused on what they're
afraid of and so more fear comes their
way and it's easy because we all have a
two million year old brain that's
designed to look for what's wrong to
protect so we protect ourselves to fight
it or to run for it or to freeze right
that's the way our old brain is wired
it's a two million year old brain but
that brings General are going to make
you happy you have to learn to take
control of your focus and if you focus
on oh my God it's never going to work or
you listen to somebody who tells you oh
that you know covet's going to be here
forever and we're never going to have
any freedom again and you focus on that
you can get really depressed as most
people have we've had 100 000 people
overdosed on drugs we have more
depression and more people in a suicidal
mode than we've ever seen in the last
two years because people need a
compelling future you can deal with a
tough today if you got a compelling
tomorrow and so what I help people do is
design that but once you change your
focus you'll change how you feel focus
and feeling go together I start with the
mind and emotions and uh to me and it's
not I don't tell people to believe uh
spiritually or religiously but I believe
prayer is a very useful thing reminding
yourself you're not the center of the
universe and asking for guidance and
help and how things do that I personally
believe that but not everybody does and
I don't tell people they have to but it
starts there but there's also when you
have a spiritual side of your life
there's a lot less anxiety because you
believe there are some thing greater
than yourself and then you do your part
like you said I usually I use a similar
metaphor and I say it's you know
trusting God and type your camels you
know that type of thing right but uh
what what most people don't know is the
power of their mind so there's an entire
last two chapters of the book if no one
reads anything else they say please read
those two chapters because if you do
everything physically well you don't
manage your mind and emotions you'll get
sick fundamentally the most basic thing
you got to do especially at a time like
covet is you gotta every day have a
couple of simple practices one of those
is every day you got to feed your mind
and when I say feed your mind I mean
consciously seek out something that's
going to give you new insight new
inspiration new way of looking things
because otherwise today the news follows
you right it's in your pocket and the
news people are good people but they're
doing their job what's their job make as
much profit as possible how do you get
the most profit get the most people to
watch I get the most people to watch
Fear if it you know if it if it leads it
leads is the phrase they use in
journalism right and we've seen so much
fear built up now that most people have
lost their faith and you can't lose it
fortunately it's just a muscle that
needs to be regained but you have to
fill your mind you have to pursue it
great ideas are not going to interrupt
you they have to be pursued and the good
news is today if you get away from just
the traditional news you can go to
podcasts like boss babes you can go to
different locations you can get another
perspective and you can feed your mind
but if you don't feed your mind my
original teacher was a guy named Jim
Rohn and he used to say Tony I got a
question for it he said what if your
worst enemy put sugar in your coffee
what's going to happen to you when you
drink that coffee so you're gonna have
sweet coffee he said you know what if
your family member your friend Your Love
by accident drops one drop of strychnine
what's gonna happen when you drink their
coffee is it you're going to be dead and
he goes That's Right life is sugar and
strychnine so watch your coffee like
every day you got to stand guard at the
door of your mind especially at times
like this when there's so much fear so
you feed your mind first of all if
you're concerned about covid according
to CDC and I have this in my new book
the number one you know issue besides
age obviously the number one piece is
being overweight right or obese that is
number one and just this week CNN New
York Times for the first time two years
later coming and saying you can reduce
your risk if you take care of your body
right do you know what number two is
according to the CDC fear because when
you get fearful it changes your
breathing your body temperature your
attention to your body all these things
can create a trigger of reactions
hormones in your body to make you crazy
so when I say fear is physical here's
what I mean you feel your physical by
the way so is courage emotions are
physical if you're really scared have
you ever been that point where you're
like freaked out about something and you
can't quite fully swallow or you've got
a feeling in your gut certainly but
courage is also physical that's what
you're talking about like it's like I
train myself from a very young age that
the number one thing I had to do so I
would follow through on the things we're
talking about here is I had to have a
mind and body that were strong together
that every day I was going to do
something to strengthen my body even if
it was just 10 minutes or 15 minutes
something was going to shift me
physiologically to do that and so I you
know I get scared or I get frustrated
and I go on a run I go on a Sprint and I
wasn't in shape didn't matter I pushed
myself Beyond where it's comfortable if
I go lift weights and I push Beyond
where I was comfortable with and when
you do that everything in your nervous
system changes because all of a sudden
when You Face something and you push
beyond the comfort zone you get stronger
and stronger even a little bit each day
changes things so think about a courage
that's not you're not afraid
because there'd be no need for courage
courage is you're scaredless but you do
it anyway yeah and so training your body
and you and I both do this right we
train intensely because we know this is
the resource through which my mind's
gonna try to make decisions and then the
second thing is every day you gotta feed
your brain your mind because if you
don't crap is going in there
automatically we all know that right
yeah I mean today it's chasing you
because we all know the news knows
they're not bad people they're good
people they're just doing their job
their job is make sure they make as much
money for their shareholders and they
know one formula works and it's pretty
obvious these last two years more than
ever if it bleeds it leads if it
produces fear more people watch it's
because we all have a two million year
old brain that's always looking for
what's wrong what can hurt us but your
two million year old brain is not going
to make you happy right you have to take
control of that 2 million year old brain
and start to direct consciously what you
want your life to be so changing your
body radically by a workout by a run by
Push by whatever you're going to do
shifting by feeding your brain every
single day and then making sure every
day you're taking some form of action
towards a compelling future like what am
I going to make better if you have
nothing to look forward to you're going
to be pissed off you're going to be
frustrated you're going to be depressed
or you're going to be overwhelmed and in
those emotional states even though
you're a smart person and you know lots
of things you won't use anything you
know so to me the leverage to changing
somebody's life is always starting with
the human body if I started to speak to
you
and I spoke more at uh
this Tempo and I said yeah I really
think people should get their act
together and make this their best year
ever right I feel terrible my body now
I'm not saying everybody needs to talk
fast or loud like me that's my own
physiology but it's gonna train but
everyone has different gears and when
you're low gears like you can be in a
great relationship somebody you totally
love and you're both in a great physical
state emotional state everything's great
you both get a little love from taking
the kids to 20 soccer practices and
Casual problems in the business and all
that stuff and all of a sudden Same Love
doesn't feel like the same love you
still love each other but it doesn't
come across and if you're both stressed
out then it creates problems in the
relationship so the most important
factor in your life is the ability to
manage your mental emotional state is
the one thing you have complete control
of once you learn how then it becomes
just the daily discipline and after it's
not even discipline it just becomes
habit just say I'm not going to live in
this lousy Pace I'm not going to put up
with it I know what to do let me do it
let me move forward but that's why you
know I do programs and events where I
immerse people yeah because you know you
and I can talk about this human it's
kind of Nod your head but if I put you
in an experience correct I always tell
people a belief is a poor substitute for
an experience you can have a belief
about China I take you to China you're
gonna have an experience it's very
different so I think human beings need
to put themselves more in experiences a
lot of us today especially with covet
being stuck at home and doing business
from home a lot of people are stuck in
their head yeah I tell you get in your
head you're dead you're just going
circles get in your head you got to get
that body and that energy moving and
then your head will start to work as
well ultimately I really believe that
the probably the most I don't know the
most sacred thing in our lives that we
can give another human being besides our
love is our labor you think about it
your labor is your energy it's your time
it's your emotion it's your intellect
it's your spirit to some extent and if
you can find a way where what you do for
a living activates that sense of what
you're made for then work is not work
whether you're being Fiji or whether you
be in a an environment that might be
seen less exciting and promising in the
moment trust me I worked in plenty of
those too but with the same level of
excitement and passion because I found
what turns me on that makes me feel
alive makes me feel like I'm doing
something that's worthwhile and on Labor
Day I think a lot of people it's just a
holiday to get away and take time off of
Labor uh and my hope is to trigger you
to think about how could you turn your
labor into your love I think it was uh
Mark Twain has said when your vocation
becomes your vacation that's when life
becomes truly magnificent and I'm
privileged enough to have that but I
pursued it and one of the secrets that I
found and I know you know this in your
soul is that we all know if you're going
to be masterful at something you don't
show up you know as the best in the
world at something you don't show up in
environments that you want to be in you
get there because you did things for
thousands and thousands of hours most of
you know the concept of Mastery taking
ten thousand hours that's an arbitrary
number but I'm sure you've heard about
you want to get really good at something
it's ten thousand hours because when you
do something enough with enough
intensity enough intention to constantly
get better when your labor is your love
and where your labor is something you
have to always get better at then
usually what happens is you get these
insights that allow you to serve more
but I also think that labor you know
we're talking about this weekend what
makes people fulfilled by their labor is
is their motives for it if your motive
is just to make money or just to pay
your bills or or just to get rich or
whatever you think that's going to be
those people never really are fulfilled
even if they make the money um the most
fulfilled human beings in my experience
and and I've had the privilege of
working with literally four million
people from 125 countries now around the
world the people that are most alive
regardless of the economics are people
that have found something that they
really feel the motive is more than just
themselves you know we all know what it
feels like when you're trying to do for
something for someone you love and
you're not doing it as a trade you're
not trying to get something back you're
just doing it because it's What You're
Made for and I always tell people motive
does matter
that if you're just doing something for
yourself there's nothing wrong with that
because life supports whatever else
supports life you're part of life and
you're trying to do something that's
going to make your life better I think
the universe God whatever proper term
for you whatever your belief system is
you know infinite intelligence gets
connected to you and it gives you
insights but I think if you're trying to
serve more than yourself more life than
just you when things support more of
life more of Life shows up to support
you and that might sound kind of Airy
fairy but it's my experience you know
when you're trying to support your
family when suddenly I had four kids
three of them overnight my life changed
my intellect change my abilities changed
because I was trying to serve something
more than just me uh when I started
really focusing on how to serve a
community and then a country and then
Humanity with corny as it may sound you
get insights you won't get when you're
just trying to somehow you know make
your labor happen or get the job done so
labor could be love and it isn't for
most people most people I think are
unhappy in their life because they look
at Labor as work they look at as why
should I have to effort so much and in
my experience effort is the reward if
you are doing something you love it's
there so if you don't have it you might
say Tony that's all wonderful you're in
Fiji and you do what you love and I
don't have that thanks so much for
giving me the lecture I'm not coming
from that place I've come from the
places saying you can discover something
that you're really passionate about but
in order to do it you got to get out of
the story of what you can't do and
you've got to put yourself on the line
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my recent interview with
Tony Robbins check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there there is a regenerative Revolution
that's happening in medicine right now
in Precision medicine billionaires know
about it but the average person doesn't
would push me over the edge recently is
I had some experiences that really hit
me hard